for those people who are kind of
unfamiliar with the craze can you just
give us a little bit of a background
about them
yeah the craze were gangsters in London
in the 1960s and rode that wave of the
London in the 60s until almost the end
of the sixties when they went to prison
and it all came to an end for everybody
but um they're very interesting because
not a lots been written about them but
there's very little that you can
actually pin down about them and know
about them so it's kind of fascinating
yeah so for Tom for you what was it were
they on your radar was it something that
Brian just came to you and said here's
this great script tell me how it came to
you um that they were always on my radar
because there's an abundance of
information and sort of iconography
about them in London and as a as
folklore history at the Kray twins are
as synonymous with crime as sort of bill
Sykes's with Dickensian London you know
in the real world but their myths are
not dissimilar there's a lot of fiction
about them as well as soon on basic
facts like when they went to prison and
you know where they lived and we all
know they loved their mom and summer but
as there was a national treasure in some
aspect of honest or dark and note as it
were within the criminal infrastructure
and historic figures so I knew of them
and it was just a question of when I you
know a film would come up about them
suppose for this this decade or this
this generation and it coming through
working title and having been penned by
Brian Helgeland was something which
automatically made it something that
wasn't going to be a salacious
sensational and some daft movie about
glamourizing criminals and brothel so it
was something was technically something
to be exciting and had been written we
have somebody who cared about telling
stories and you know
and there's a very fertile piece of real
estate that came to the door so I'm
definitely something I went there dude
and play both brothers as well I'm glad
stuff so shut up Tom
so you decide oh shut up
it's a bride you decide I'm drinking Tom
Hardy's gonna play both brothers um how
do you know well not even how did you
know he's gonna pull off we know he's
gonna he's an amazing actor okay but but
how do you pull about how do you know we
was gonna come through for you so well
well you always the only thing everyone
knows how to do their job really I do
you know and he did um I went to him to
play Reggie and we met more truffle
french fries yeah I let you do and often
is the case when men getting together
having some truffle french fries and I
asked them to play Reggie and he wanted
to play Ron and at the end of the hole
by the time the plate was cleared he he
said look give me Reggie and I'll give
you Ron and we went from there so I'm
watching this performance and I'm
thinking who on earth was more
challenging or harder to play um but
they actually in hindsight both but my
initial response was D if I had to
choose one brother because that's how it
was laid out in the first place I
automatically gravitate towards Ron
because there was more there was it was
much more freedom to play with there as
a performer and iSight had to be a bit
more careful with one because there's a
way of lambasting being cartoonish or to
an extent where you missed the point of
the clown effort is not to joke about
things but to create a certain level of
humor whereby people laugh along and
then don't realize that what they're
laughing at is not something that's
funny at all it's incredibly serious so
the balance was something was specific
in an experiment looking back
experiencial hindsight wise but Reggie
was harder to play because he navigates
terrain with a veneer which hides his
interior landscape
and from the majority of the film he
portrays is portrayed you know as a
heroic lead in romantic sort of affirm
hero which didn't sit entirely with my
understanding of that that one must be
very careful I think with the balancing
out between real people and a movie or
fill most tale based on real people so
the tricky trying to navigate yeah I
mean it's quite extraordinary you're
watching and I honestly believe that I'm
watching two separate actors and and are
you lucky
well I want to know I mean how how hard
is it to turn off one turn on the other
like what was the process that's very
easy the application is very easy it's a
due diligence prior preparation and
deciding and signing off with Brian how
they would look and what differentiate
the two guys silhouette wise local
landscape physical landscape with
costume and makeup and all the effects
and then how technically to shoot them
you know once we got through shoot our
way through all of that which is quite
daunting to be fair became a practical
application of slow method and then
became really good fun when we committed
to doing it know trying to solve that
puzzle on a daily basis to make it more
seamless that an alive yeah in a way Tom
had to come on board the technical side
of it in a way an actor hasn't usually
have to beyond here's a green screen and
someday there's going to be a spaceship
up there it's not there right now but um
he had to imagine instead of a spaceship
yet to imagine the actor that was across
from him and there were all kinds of
things to help and he had a great body
double take of who came in but at the
end of the day he still had to conjure
up the other the other side of the
equation yeah but I see the helps
because I know how I will respond at
least yeah so that cut to that quick in
some aspects of that what options would
I give myself based on how I've read
both characters come to the day so that
wasn't but it was how to make that alive
yeah so we didn't become a gimmick which
which is what we are not struggled with
but that was a lot of
the FO on the day was happenin I to
incorporate our ensemble in our team so
that it was alive for everybody and not
again pull it to the gimmick and as much
as we planned it ahead of time there
were always it was always something that
would come up that you wouldn't think of
so we were always learning it as we went
along and and and incorporating new
things as we learned what we can do and
how far we can go with it we we
incorporated the next day and the next
day and the next day and it'd be good to
do again now yeah or that would matter
on what we know back here what's
possible and it's quite extraordinary
with the scene that just blew me away
was all there was to like when you get
up and you're touching each other's
knees which I thought was so cool but
the fight scene the fight scene like
were you exhausted
yeah but it was such a it was such a
great it was so full on everyone's
putting in their eye and their input how
to make this illusion work and there
were so many opportunities there to
obviously fall apart and you and see
behind the curtain that they you know
saw this is the same person etc so in
and shooting anything moving when you've
got to you know if you've got a static
shot of the brothers talking to one
another's it's obviously gonna be
slightly more simple you just thought of
my lights whenever they're in the same
room but to have them moving and
constantly interacting that was a bit
off piste yeah yeah very quickly just
have to ask about Emily Browning just
working with her what it was actually
she's fantastic in that and and I think
arguably she had the hardest job out of
all of us in acting Mamta too because
she's the sobering and most honest in
many ways ground in character in the
piece though we see through our eyes and
ultimately gets caught between these two
and triangle between these two chaos
sort of Makati characters who are deeply
dysfunctional she's part of that but she
saw our story is much more
there's she's the most human I feel
element of the piece and key